どうも皆さんこんにちはっ♪
はじめんですっ♪
え～皆さんスマホ知ってますでしょうか？
スマートフォンとは何故スマホと呼ばれているかと言うと
先進的な携帯機器OSを備えた携帯機器の一種でございます
従来の携帯電話フューチャーフォンやパソコンの機能を取り込んである携帯端末とされるが
位置的に明確な定義は今のところ無いと言われております
日本ではスマホ、スマフォ、ケータイとも省されています
なので皆スマホスマホ言ってますけども
具体的にスマホっていう定義は無くて
まぁ何か…あの
ボタンが少なくて、大画面一個ついてたら何かスマホっぽいなっていうイメージだと思います
何かスマホだけ買うんじゃなくて大抵スマホを買うと
この…フィルターケースを貼ったり
僕も付けてるんですけどこのケースですね
ケース付けないと傷ついたりするんで付けてるですけども
僕、やっぱり
なくしちゃうんですよ
相変わらずのごとくスマホも何回とも
もう数知れぬほどなくしてきたんで
スマホ結構なくしちゃってて
どうしようと思って
なんか動画の撮影とか
静かにしなきゃいけないことが多いから
基本的に…
マナーモードなんですよ
非常になくしやすい
なくすスマートフォンなら…
そもそも
そもそものスマートフォン自体を大きくすればいい
あってますよね？
あってると思いますよ
ええもちろん合ってると思います
というわけで今回はですね
え、待ってスマートフォン
スマホのケースって一番大きいのどれくらいのサイズだろ
大きなスマホケースってあんまりないんですよ
あ～そんなもんかはいはいはい
あぁそんなもんねっ！　ははっｗ
今巨大スマホケースで調べたんですけども
まぁせいぜい大きくてもなんか
バナナケースみたいなこういうスマホか
虫のついてる大きいぐらいしか無いですね
小さぁぁぁい！！　なくすんでしょぉぉぉ！？
え～実はですね、僕専用の
超巨大なスマホケースを実は特別に作って頂いておりまして
今回それが届いたというお話でございます
はいこちらっ！
これが俺の新しいスマホケースですっ！！
これだけ大きかったら多分なくすことも無いだろうっていうね
天才的な発想だと思うよ！
うわぁありがてぇ！
ショルダーバックみたいなカバンになってる！
すげぇドライバーとかもついてる！
伊達に特注じゃないぜ！
ドライバーもついてるよぉ
というわけでこちらが
俺の知る限りそしてネットで見る限りは
になっておりますっ！
開けてみましょう
いや～なんか色々デザインの注文はしたんですけど
実物見るのはホント初めてなんですよね
失礼しますっ
ｳﾜｯ!?
ｳｪｯ!?
結構カッコいいぞこれ！！
うわっ！？えっ！？凄い凄い凄い！！
待って待って結構凄いぞ！！
はっはっはｗｗ
うわぁ～！！
はいこちらで～すｗｗ
すげぇ！なんか
これっぽい感じで作ってくださいって言ったんですけども
角とかすごいそれっぽいぞ
はいというわけでこれが世界最大級のスマホケースです！！
今使ってるやつとほぼ一緒のデザインというか
ここの…なんか
落ちても大丈夫なやつになってます
こんな感じになっております
あ…凄い…
そしてちゃんとここには
はじめしゃちょーのロゴ入りでございます
すげぇ！かっけぇ！！
そしてちゃんとスマホを入れる部分もあるんですけども
電源ボタンも押せないし
音量のボタンも押せないので
そこを押す用の空間だけはちゃんと開けてあります
一回スマホ入れてみますか！
ｱｯ…
え待ってこれどうやって入れんの？
もうこうしかないよね？
ひょっとしてネジで外さなきゃいけないのかな？
ネジで開けないとダメだ…ｗ
ちょっとネジで開けます！
おっけ～！
あぁ～ここにスマホを入れるのかぁ
入れてみます…
いいねぇいいねぇ！
よぉし出来ましたぁ！
はい！スマホが入りました！
これ凄いのがちゃんと写真も撮れるように
後ろにカメラの部分だけちゃんと穴が開いてるんですよ
なので普通にこうやって写真は撮れるわけですよ
全然写真はね　問題なく撮れます
すげぇ全然使えるわ
はい！というわけでこれだけ大きなスマホケースだったら
多分なくさないと思います
いやホントちゃんと写真も撮れるし
あの電源もちゃんとここで押せるし
音量もここでちゃんと下げたりできて
写真もちゃんと撮れるので
え～っと実用性はちゃんとあります
で落としても画面の割れる心配がありません
というわけでちょっと今日から
（おいおいおいはじめさ～ん）
（よく考えろよっ）
（絶っっ対めんどくさいや～ん）
（ちょっと短めにしとこうかなっ！）
一週間！
今日から一週間ちょっとこちらのスマホケースで
生活してみようと思います
そしてこちら！気になる値段はなんとっ！！
３８万円っ！！！
（エンディング）
（LINEの着信音～♪）
もしもし？